tenemos las noticias de la economía con
Juan Pablo lucum y Juan Pablo saludo
nuevamente acá estamos otra vez
empezamos con la noticia que mueve los
mercados mundiales al menos en los
términos de los combustibles Así es
Ángela hablamos de la decisión de Rusia
que se conoció este viernes
Moscú dijo que reducirá su producción de
petróleo en 500.000 barriles por día
esto en marzo una decisión que según
fuentes de la OPEP más se dio sin el
consentimiento del club de los grandes
países exportadores de petróleo la
reducción de la producción que equivale
alrededor del 5% de la producción de
enero había sido insinuada por el
kremlin Desde que la Unión Europea y el
g7 comenzaron a discutir sobre el tope
de precios de las exportaciones rusas
este nuevo escenario presiona los
precios del crudo que antes no se había
visto pues tan afectado con las
prohibiciones de Occidente
parece que el Reino Unido se salva de la
recesión por ahora de por ahora digamos
que se salva eso con los resultados del
último trimestre de 2022 porque su
crecimiento económico fue nulo fue de
cero no fue ni negativo ni positivo y
aunque esquiva la recesión el país
todavía lucha con un reducir la
inflación la más alta en 40 años cuando
se ubicó en el 10,5% anual en diciembre
Lo cierto es que el banco de Inglaterra
pronosticó la semana pasada que Reino
Unido sí entraría en una recesión dijo
que sería superficial pero prolongada y
que podría comenzar entre enero y marzo
de este año y duraría por lo menos cinco
trimestres Esto fue lo que dijo el
secretario de economía británico al
respecto
hemos evitado la recesión pero no
estamos fuera de peligro la inflación
sigue siendo demasiado alta lo que está
causando dolor en las familias de todo
el país por eso debemos apegarnos a
nuestro plan para reducir la inflación a
la mitad si hacemos eso y aprovechamos
nuestras fortalezas en ciencia y
tecnología realmente podemos ser uno de
los países más prósperos de Europa
y hay actualización sobre el acuerdo
entre Pakistán y el fmi Así es Ángela
una noticia que conocimos hace pocos
minutos porque el comité económico de
Pakistán aprobó el plan de gestión de la
deuda que estaba haciendo negociado con
el fmi negociaciones que giraban en
torno a la reanudación de los
desembolsos de un gran préstamo
escalonado de 6.500 millones de dólares
del cual hasta el momento sólo se ha
desembolsado un poco menos de la mitad
escuchemos
como resultado de esta revisión
tendremos derecho a un tramo de 1200
millones de dólares y se dará a conocer
después de que el consejo ejecutivo los
haya revisado reanudaremos las
discusiones virtuales con el memorándum
de políticas económicas y financieras el
lunes exactamente el viernes pasado
funcionarios de Pakistán decían que el
fmi estaba bloqueando esta millonaria
ayuda a que su país tanto necesita
Cuáles fueron las razones para que se
retrasara el desembolso para que las
acusaciones que hacía el gobierno en su
momento y de las cuales estuvimos
hablando Pues el fmi se ha disgustado en
repetidas ocasiones porque Pakistán no
ha cumplido con los compromisos que el
fondo le ha pedido la organización
financiera internacional le solicitaba a
Pakistán que hicieran nuevos aumentos en
el precio de la gasolina y la
electricidad esto para enfrentar el
problema estructural a lo que ha llamado
deuda circular del sector energético le
ha pedido una reducción del déficit
presupuestario el fin de las elecciones
de impuestos a la exportación y mejorar
el panorama de impuestos
otras razones que dan algunos
funcionarios de Pakistán pues no se ha
cumplido porque esto por el temor a que
estos cambios financieros le pasen
facturan las urnas cuando se den las
elecciones legislativas que están
pronosticadas para final de año sin
embargo el gobierno Sí cumplió con dos
requisitos del fmi 1 renunció a sus
intervenciones en el mercado cambiario y
aumentó el precio de la gasolina ahora
con el fin de la política de cero covid
llega el aumento de la inflación a china
Así es un escenario que se da porque
pues aumenta el consumo las personas
pues empezaron a consumir especialmente
en comida y Eso lo veremos a
continuación en el siguiente gráfico Un
aumento de los precios también en el
tiquete de avión esto todo por el fin de
la política de Cero covid y personas que
estaban más de tres años confinadas
salieron a consumir básicamente y vemos
el resultado de un incremento anual del
2,1% por debajo si el de septiembre pero
por encima del de diciembre e incluso el
de noviembre básicamente un escenario
que ya lo estaban advirtiendo todos los
líderes del foro de davos cuando decían
muy bien china pues va a haber otra vez
la reapertura Pero esto no será bueno
para todo el mundo y Puede que sea
negativo y aquí estamos viendo una
inflación interna y ya veremos qué pasa
con el resto del mundo Juan Pablo cómo
van los indicadores estamos también a la
espera de que Wall Street abra hasta las
9:30 horas Bogotá quito y Lima Pero
entonces vamos con las bolsas asiáticas
Porque cerraron en terreno mixto con el
anuncio del posible gobernador del Banco
Central de Japón en el cual ya hay
nombre y con el nuevo dato de inflación
de China que acabamos de revisar hace
unos minutos las bolsas europeas siguen
operando en terreno negativo teniendo
presente las decisiones que tomará la
Unión Europea frente a las peticiones
del presidente de Ucrania y la decisión
de Rusia y la OPEP Juan Pablo gracias a
usted